the gi joe movie franchise has been
missing in action but if there's one guy
who can rescue it it's the ninja known
as snake eyes
the character is returning in an all-new
series reboot here's everything you need
to know about snake eyes gi joe origins
the first bit of news about the snake
eyes movie that the public heard came
out over three years ago way back in may
2018
at the time the hollywood reporter
confirmed that paramount pictures had
put into development to gi joe's
spin-off film centered around snake eyes
tapping the live-action beauty and the
beast movie screenwriter evan
spilatopoulos to pen the script and
brian goldner to produce
the outlet also noted that executives at
paramount and hasbro had been keen on
rebooting the gi joe franchise and it
commissioned a writer's room dedicated
to developing movies and cinematic
universes around hasbro properties
including gi joe transformers mask and
micronauts
by all accounts the snake eye solo flake
was one such idea
and according to an interview producer
lorenzo d bonaventura gave to
entertainment weekly in 2021 it was one
of the only solid
ideas that writer's room happened to
produce things were relatively quiet on
the snake eyes front until december 2018
when robert schwenke signed on as the
film's director audiences will know
schwenke is the director behind movies
like the time traveler's wife
ripd the divergent series insurgent and
the divergent series allegiant
in 2010's gi joe the rise of cobra in
2013's gi joe retaliation
the scottish martial artist ray park
played snake eyes in december 2018
gi joe franchise producer lorenzo de
bonaventura confirmed with slash film
that ray park wouldn't be reprising his
role for the character's origin story
leaving the possibilities for the movie
wide open
it wasn't until mid 2019 that the snake
eyes gi joe origins cast started to come
together
and a few more months after that before
the movie kicked off production
so if rey park isn't snake eyes then who
is that'd be malaysian english actor
henry golding
whose performance is nick young in the
beloved romantic comedy crazy rich
asians has led to roles in the feature
films of simple faber monsoon
last christmas and the gentleman through
snake eye's gi joe origins a talented
actor will be taken on his first leading
role in an action movie and he has a
heck of a supporting cast surrounding
him
snake eyes also stars ready or not and
bill and ted face the music actress
samara weaving as scarlet a fierce gi
joe agent who also works for clan arashi
kage
money high star ursula cabarro as the
baroness a member of the terrorist
organization cobra
peter mencha of marvel's agents of
shield fame as clan arashi kage's
co-leader blind master
andrew koji of the excellent cinematic
series warrior as snake eyes friend
turned deadly nemesis storm shadow and
haruka abe as akiko a clan arashi kage
trainee with connections to snake eyes
and storm shadow rounding out the cast
of snake eyes our eco aways to storm
shadow's uncle hard master
who leads clan arashi kage takihiro hira
as cobra member kenta
and steven ulrich as snake eyes father
playing a character as famous as snake
eyes and a franchise as action heavy as
gi joe would require
even in shape actors to get more ripped
in preparation henry golding whom no one
would consider unmuscular in his
everyday life got totally shredded to
play snake eyes
undergoing intense training that yielded
impressive results
in november 2020 golding said that he
became a weapon during snake eyes gi joe
origins prep
and even shared a jaw-dropping clip from
one of his training sessions on the
tonight show with jimmy fallon
they put me through my paces we have
like four hours of choreography
every single day we have two hours of
script work then like an
hour of pt according to golding the
producers of snake eyes went out on a
limb and casting him having faith that
he would be able to build on his boxing
and martial arts background to become a
credible super soldier
that bat seems to have paid off in a big
way it was worth it because
i became a weapon i'm not gonna lie the
snake ice gi joe origins cast and crew
began filming in october 2019
shooting in vancouver canada from the
15th of that month to the 9th of
december
when vancouver's shooting rap the
production moved to a new locale
tokyo japan the cast and crew spent
about six weeks in japan and in late
february 2020 golden announced that all
principal photography for snake eyes was
complete
writing in an instagram post and that is
a principle wrap on snake eyes ladies
and gents
what a crew we have vancouver in japan
you are unstoppable thank you for the
dedication this film is going to blow
everyone's socks off
initially snake eyes was slated for a
theatrical release on march 27
2020. like many movies originally slated
for that year it ended up going through
some release date reshuffling
eventually being taken off of
paramount's release schedule entirely
over a year later in march 2021 golden
came forward with another announcement
about filming
snake eyes was undergoing reshoots in an
instagram post about the reshoots golden
acknowledged the difficulty of filming
under covet protocols and expressed his
happiness that they were still able to
pull it off in spite of it
we just got some reshoots for snake eyes
but i'm so grateful that we're able to
pull this off
after those last minute reshoots the
film is now officially set to land in
theaters on july 23
2021. first and foremost snake eyes will
be an origin story and as such fans will
get to see the events that transform him
into the masked silent badass they know
and love
in the gi joe animated series and in the
marvel comics snake eyes
silence has been chalked up to damage
vocal chords but that fact was retconned
for the feature films
snake eyes doesn't say a word in gi joe
the rise of cobra and gi joe retaliation
because he previously took a vow of
silence following the apparent murder of
one of his masters at the hands of storm
shadow the film's story will focus on
snake eyes accepting an invitation to
begin training with the arashi kage a
clan of japanese ninja
the process will prove more difficult
than anyone bargained for as the truth
about snake eyes pass comes to the
surface
his mind and harder tested and his body
is pushed to its limits
of course with storm shadow as a key
member of the character roster there
should be an epic showdown between the
dangerous man and his former friend
snake eyes
remarks that star henry golding has made
indicate that snake eyes will be charged
with a weighty task
rebooting the entire gi joe film series
during a press conference in january
2020 the actor said
the movie is unlike anything people will
have seen we're really starting a new
timeline a new franchise within the gi
joe universe
to kick it off with such a distinct and
stylized film i think it really sets the
precedent for follow-up movies
while one could make the case that
paramounts at hasbro are jumping the gun
by rebooting the series after only two
films it seems like a smart move
gi joe has the potential to be a smash
hit property along the lines of the fast
and furious and mission impossible
franchises
but it hasn't happened yet previous
entries in the franchise rise of cobra
and retaliation
underperformed critically and
commercially in his past comments
golding perhaps inadvertently pinned
down one big reason for this
a lack of personality snake eyes can fix
that reintroducing the franchise by way
of an origin flick for its most
compelling and unique character
those thanksgi joe origins has yet to
open in theaters paramount and hasbro
executives already have a sequel in the
works
a hollywood reporter broke the news in
an exclusive report on may 1st 2020
detailing that rebecca and seberg
writers joe shrapnel and anna waterhouse
teamed up to co-write the script for
snake eyes 2.
lorenzo d bonaventura is returning to
produce and of course henry golding is
circling back to star with snake eyes
there isn't a whole lot of information
about the snake eye sequel out there
just yet
and vans will have to wait to see the
first flick to know what might happen in
a second
it stands to reason that snake eye's gi
joe origins could end with its eponymous
character taking a vow of silence or
venturing to never show his face again
although doing both while canonically
accurate might make for an underwhelming
follow-up film
lucasfilm's disney plus streaming series
the mandalorian proved that a project's
main character doesn't have to show
their face at all times pedro pascal's
din jaren almost never takes his helmet
off but that they should at least speak
up every now and then keep things
interesting there's also bonus points of
course for the masked character showing
some wit and humor when they do engage
in conversation how will fans feel if
snake eyes hides his face but not his
voice or vice versa
instead of doing both down the line in
any case it says a lot
that paramounts on hasbro greenlit a
sequel well before snake eyes debuted
fingers crossed that when snake eyes gi
joe origins debuts on july 23rd
it'll blow everyone away check out one
of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one